well she thinks it's politics I don't
think it's good politics Nancy Pelosi
has been blocking it Schumer has been
blocking it and I think they think it's
good politics I don't think it's good
politics I think it's bad politics but I
don't care about the politics it's so
great for our country because Nancy
Pelosi is blocking it she sits in her
house in San Francisco overlooking the
ocean and she doesn't want to come back
she doesn't want to come back she
doesn't want to come back to DC she's
got to get back and get this thing
approved it's very important that was
the president yesterday at the briefing
talking about the prospects of a deal to
reef replenish the coffers of the PPP
program that's helped helped and could
help so many small businesses
let's bring in California GOP
congressmen Devin Nunez ranking member
the house Intel committee member of the
House Ways and Means Committee as well
congressman thanks for joining us where
are we right now
I mean we and and is is Nancy Pelosi
playing an aboveboard game here and
where are we in getting a deal well
thank you for having me on what I would
say is that if any Republican leader of
Mitch McConnell or Kevin McCarthy or any
of our speakers in the past would have
said done something like Pelosi did
where she's sitting at home in front of
a refrigerator with a you know $24,000
you know freezer that I don't think too
many of us have except maybe for Griff I
think he may have won but but here's the
deal it would be a fatal flaw I mean we
would we would boot McConnell or
McCarthy out of leadership just like
that they would have been out four days
ago the minute that that popped up when
you have you know people 20 million
people unemployed you have people they
can't get paychecks you just had on the
last segment
they can't even mow their damn lawn in
Michigan what the hell is going on any
oh she's sitting in San Francisco you
know eating gourmet ice cream Minh try
out in the real world you know Congress
right now full disclosure my fridge is
so tiny my donors complain we can barely
give one pint of ice cream in there but
let me ask you because Pelosi put out a
letter yesterday last night about the
talks are ongoing in she's feeling
confident about
progress being made can you take us
inside what you're hearing about talks
and how close we are to actually seeing
movement this week well we had a
conference call yesterday we have
another one scheduled for tonight I know
that the Republican leader McCarthy is
on his way back to Washington when right
now and we're gonna have another
conference call so the idea is is that
you would plus up the money for the
Paycheck protection so that we can keep
people employed and also give money for
hospitals that seems like a logical
great plan has huge bipartisan support I
think it's one the American people would
understand do you have confidence
that'll get done this week well I would
think so it's like I said at the
beginning when you have a leader that's
that that makes such a fatal flaw what
would be a fatal flaw for a Republican
for a Democrat the media is covering it
up because you know fox and a few others
are the only ones covering that but if
you have Mitch McConnell with a bunch of
gourmet ice cream he'd be thrown out of
leadership immediately you're totally
right double standard is glaring by the
way can you prevent any Kennedy Center
type funding as we saw in the last one
where they slipped in money for their
friends I mean how are they going to try
to do that again well we can't the only
way you can prevent it is by not giving
them the votes okay but at the end of
the day you have to judge is it okay to
not be paying people that can't mow
their lawn in Michigan versus twenty
five million dollars for whatever the
hell the Democrats want to use for the
Kennedy Center which I said last week on
your show still has not been turned into
a kovat response Center last time I
checked very very true Karen let me take
you to a different topic for just a
moment I've been Pete's been egging me
on I've really been pressing hard on
China the president warned China could
be facing consequences yesterday and of
course you've got for Vice President
Biden weighing in as well let me just
give you a little bit of what the
president said about Chinese consequence
doesn't get your reaction here's the
president well if they were knowingly
who responsible certainly if they did if
it was a mistake a mistake is a mistake
but if they were knowingly responsible
yeah then there should be consequences
you're talking about you know
potentially lives like nobody's seen
since 1917 I think you have numerous
countries waiting to see whether or not
sleepy Joe wins because if sleepy Joe
won they own our country for years I've
heard by 2019 China will catch us
there's only one problem Trump got
elected in 2016 reaction so the House
Republicans have been running an
investigation into China on the
Intelligence Committee for many many
years we were the first to identify that
we had a five G problem that Huawei and
ZTE Chinese companies were looking to
own all of the networks all over the
globe so we've been on this for a while
and remember we were dealing with the
Russia hoax in the last Congress at the
same time the House Republicans were
trying to run an investigation into
China and the Democrats
finally we had a public hearing on this
and they hijacked the hearing to try to
subpoena whatever Russian of the week
they were they were looking after and so
you know this has been a challenge for
us to to get China on the forefront I
think now both Republicans and Democrats
realize this and I'll just have to
finish that the issue with this virus in
China the unusual part from the
beginning of this is just how contagious
this virus has been and what we need to
know is did they do something to this
virus to speed it up yeah and I think
that's the that's the real question that
we've answered by the Chinese the first
year so you mentioned the investigations
I got to get your tape newly
unclassified footnotes show that the FBI
knew that documents used for FISA
warrants were bogus
explain this so what your what the
American people are seeing is is
everything's coming into clearer view
what the Republicans on the House
Intelligence Committee have been looking
at for a while the documents that have
been that have been Declassified there's
been a lot of documents Declassified in
the last week I'd sum it up like this
and this is this is really important for
folks that follow this Russia hoax
closely if you look at theirs there's
essentially three what I would call
phony documents also called dossiers you
have the steal Clinton fusion GPS
dossier that's that the FBI was involved
in there's a bunch of questions there
Durham's looking at
you have the intelligence community
assessment that was done by the Obama
administration in the waning days of
2016 before Obama left office and Donald
Trump came in remember that was a
document that said oh yeah the Russians
were trying to help Trump well now we
know there's lots of lies and omissions
which I would say not only mislead
Congress but mislead the American people
the third dossier I would say was what
is what people call the molar report the
molar report I call the molar dossier
okay because it's also filled with both
lies and omissions and remember you have
people that have been prosecuted over
this that have already spent time in
jail over this why why when Moeller and
his team there you know this great team
of experts at DOJ and FBI they brought
all these people in where the hell's all
that information now that you guys are
all now seen for the first time here in
the last week you know why did we not
know about these about George
papadopolis being offered this money
okay from from Russians who were those
Russians and so moving forward you have
the three dossiers that have to be
investigated I'm also interested in
three Russians that are actually Russian
Americans that we meet that we're
looking into and then I would say
finally in 2016 we know from great work
that trey Gowdy did at the time in
questioning that the CIA gave
information over to the FBI in 2016 we
now are laser-focused on that we need to
know exactly what did the CIA give to
the FBI in 2016 that's what our
investigation is now focusing on very
you see yeah if we get that congressman
I doubt they're gonna open that in the
house and smoke rats are in control but
maybe Senator Lindsey Graham who now
runs a douchey Airy committee will take
a deeper look yeah you've been on the
case from the beginning thanks for
staying on at congressman we appreciate
it absolutely and Griff your mole that's
looking good ma'am yes get a MOLLE thank
you thanks